-I want to ask about this.
Doing this documentary,
you had to talk about yourself
a lot on film.
-Yeah. I hated that.
-But then you had to watch it.
-That was horrible.
-The watching or the talking?
-Yeah. Every part of it.
I --
This filmmaker, Neil Berkeley,
came up to me.
And he said,
"I´ve always wanted to do a
Gilbert Gottfried documentary."
And I said, "Well, you should
set your dreams
a lot higher than that."
-But then he made
this wonderful film.
You -- One of the things
we found out --
I want to mention
that clip real quick.
You are a hoarder, it seems.
-Yeah, yeah, I could be
on any one of those shows.
-Uh-huh.
-It´s like --
See, I think mainly
anything I can get for free.
If someone came up and said,
"I´ve got a carton of
sanitary napkins" or something,
I´d go, "Okay, yeah."
You´d take that?
-I´m sure I could find
a use for those.
-Your children,
your wife are in the film?
-Yes.
-Do your children
think you are funny?
-My son,
when he was in preschool,
the teacher said,
"He´s always --
He doesn´t pay attention.
And he´s always trying
to crack jokes."
And I thought, "Yeah, I´m going
to really beat him for this.
Yeah. I don´t know
where he gets this from."
And she said, "Where´d you
learn how to be funny?"
And he said, "From my daddy."
And she said,
"Oh, your daddy´s funny?"
He goes, "He´s funny at home,
not at work."
[ Laughter ]
-He heckled you.
-Uh, yes.
-He heckled you to a teacher.
-Yeah.
And I have to respect anyone
who doesn´t admire me
as a performer.
-[ Laughs ]
You talk about a couple
of incidents where you
have gotten in trouble
for jokes that you did.
One of them, I believe --
-Luckily,
it stayed out of the press.
-Yeah. You have had --
-And it stayed off the Internet.
-One was you told a 9/11 joke
right after --
right after 9/11
at a Hugh Hefner roast.
-Yeah. It was --
It was like a couple of days
after September 11th.
People are booing and hissing.
One guy yelled out, "Too soon."
Which I thought meant I didn´t
take a long enough pause
between the setup
and the punch line.
And then I figure
why not go to the
bottom level of hell?
And I go in,
I tell the Aristocrats joke.
-Now, this is funny.
Because we´re talking
about one documentary,
but the telling
of The Aristocrats joke
led to a different documentary
about the history of the joke.
Yeah, it´s called
"The Aristocrats," oddly enough.
-And that was --
That´s sort of a filthy joke.
And it sort of won --
You won the room back.
-It showed, like,
in situations like that,
people need to laugh.
They really want to laugh.
In the documentary,
there´s a part
where I´m doing a benefit
at St. Jude´s Hospital,
which is by no stretch
a funny place.
-Of course not.
-It´s, like,
a children´s hospital.
And I went up --
I thought, for sure, this would
destroy what I had of a career.
And people were --
It did great.
´Cause people
desperately want to laugh.
-And breaking tension
is sort of the root
of what it is that you do.
I want to ask, because the Emmys
were just last night,
Two nights ago, I should say.
You hosted the ´91 Emmys.
-Yes.
-And they had to put you
on a delay, yes?
-Yeah. I think --
I think I´m the reason --
I think, before that,
they didn´t have a delay
with the Emmys.
And I´m pretty sure
afterwards --
Because it was the year
that Pee-wee Herman --
he was in a porn theater doing
what people do in porn theaters.
-Yeah.
-He was playing with pee-wee.
And --
And, so, I went on stage.
And I said,
"I really sleep better at night
knowing Pee-wee Herman´s
been arrested.
If masturbation´s a crime,
I should be on death row."
[ Laughter ]
And how did they know
he was masturbating?
Did they dust for prints?
[ Laughter ]
And, you know, and right now --
And to think that by age 12,
I was already Al Capone.
[ Laughter ]
Like, you could put a charcoal
in my right hand,
and I´ll crush it
into a diamond.
And I was never invited back
to the Emmys.
-Yeah. There you go.
Their loss.
I promise you, it´s their loss.
We could have used it
a couple nights ago.
We all would have been
very happy with that.
Thank you so much
for being here.
-Thank you.
-Congrats on the documentary.
Always a pleasure.